assis le regard fixe et attentif ces
marcheurs et coups de pierres un
versailles et qui a l'idée de remplacer
le noir par du blanc dans les villes un
mètre carré un mètre carré de surface
noire
c'est comme si vous mettez deux
radiateurs dehors si on arrive à avoir
une vraie vie qui est plutôt blanche on
aura moins de réchauffement de la ville
et si on avait plutôt noir on va voir
une surchauffe de la ville alors on peut
le faire chez soi sur sa terrasse du
jardin
on peut le faire quand on est membre d
un conseil syndical du blanc à la place
du noir l'avantagé surtout pour
l'environnement il intéresse aussi les
habitants invités à donner leur avis et
conseils
j'apporte par contre mon père mon
oreille le citoyen est donc de réagir à
une idée qui m'est proposé est de prêter
plus challengé on a challenge est pas
comme sur le coup sûr comment et ployer
ce genre d'idée savoir s'il y avait des
effets micro c'était que des effets
macro une dizaine de porteurs de projets
étaient présents pour ces ateliers
citoyens la république en marche se fixe
dans les yvelines la mise en place de
130 projets locaux d'ici la fin du
quinquennat
éducation sociale ou encore santé
l'objectif est d'inciter les citoyens à
régler par eux mêmes les problèmes de
tous les jours
nous sommes tous en mesure de régler des
problèmes à notre échelle
par exemple nous avons lancé un projet
de seniors tech pour lutter contre la
fracture numérique des aînés qui sont
souvent qu'ils savent pas trop comment
gérer l'ordinateur alors que de plus en
plus de choses se font sur ordinateur et
à chanter les villes est un projet qui
est lancé lancé également en direction
des prochaines élections ces ateliers
ont pour but politique de faire émerger
des marcheurs en vue des élections
municipales de 2020